and this alert because we are awaiting
now those new numbers on the border
crisis
homeland security secretary mayorkus
is in southern texas today to
see up close how the situation has
exploded in fact he's expected to speak
july's monthly migrant encounters
wow let's just call it what it is people
trying to get into the country who've
had to be apprehended otherwise would be
running around illegally
those numbers are expected to reach
another 20-year high
we're looking at potentially 210
000
of those apprehensions last month alone
that's up 188 000
in june we're told to expect record
numbers today and we are also getting
brand new video of the cramped
conditions at this one facility in the
rio grande valley remember we've been
watching people come over by the
thousands at that point every week
live on camera with our crew down there
dozens packed into this one small
concrete room with barely enough space
for anybody to lie down republican
congressman chip roy on the faulkner
focus just a short time ago
told me the administration had better
get its act together
secretary marcus and president biden and
obviously vice president harris are
completely m.i.a and i think frankly
it's purposeful uh they're purposely
ignoring their duty to defend the
borders of the united states we know
that seven thousand covet positive
people were dumped into the communities
of mcallen and mayorkas and biden and
harris don't care yet we're the ones in
danger that's why
andy biggs is correct and i've been
calling for impeaching the homeland
security for failing to do his job
impeachment
of the dhs secretary joey
yeah it's a terrible situation down
there listen i come from a town that's
78 hispanic inside the city limits
dalton georgia is a multi-racial
multicultural city in northwest georgia
because it's a textile industry all the
carpets made there the jobs were there
in the 80s and 90s when immigration
spiked at some of its largest points and
so the reason why i point that out is
this is a personal issue for me and to
be called bigoted or racist because you
want security and order is just
completely false and let me tell you why
first in generation mexican immigrants
don't like open borders they want order
and they want an opportunity for their
parents that came here illegally and
their family that's still in mexico to
have a legal path to come here and be
with them and visit them and be a part
of the american system people coming
across the border illegally live in the
shadows they don't have the
opportunities we have and democrats want
it that way because when you live in the
shadows and you're disenfranchised you
have to rely on big broad easily access
government programs just to survive like
the department of health and things of
that nature that's why democrats don't
have a problem with people coming here
illegally and being disenfranchised from
actual citizenship president trump
offered nancy pelosi the best deal
democrats could have fund the border
we'll get daca and we'll talk about a
path to citizenship and nancy pelosi
couldn't give him enough of a win to
make that happen so here we are years
later still dealing with this in the
worst of ways wow and your comments are
so deep and wide on the perspective and
the name calling quite frankly toward
conservatives and you explain so much
there joey um so my big question then is
why didn't democrats just take the win
was it because it was put forth by
donald trump
kaylee it's exactly why they didn't take
the win these were trump policies they
were warned by the secretary of state by
others that it would be a catastrophe if
they rolled back part of title 42 remain
in mexico policy these successful
policies of trump the border wall
ceasing construction there but they did
it anyway because they simply do not
care i agree with joey on that point or
rather chip roy uh that sound bite we
heard he made that point you know
where's kamala harris she said it was a
humanitarian catastrophe on the southern
border during the trump era where is she
now when we have this picture from the
rio grande valley sector that will pop
up where these are migrants and cages
you heard a lot about these cages during
the trump era what about this biden era
cage and of course during the trump era
that cage turned out to be an obama cage
children in cages but again the media
never corrected themselves but now you
have these shocking images deplorable
conditions horrible reports of kids
eating undercooked food and where is the
biden administration mark morgan made
that very point he said this where is
the mainstream media where are the open
border advocates and the democrats who
had crocodile tears in 2019 where are
they now they are absent
you know leslie you and i have on many
times tv radio gone back and forth just
trying to get to the realities of the
situation how it is for people on the
ground
and that's where i want to go with you
now
biden has to take a look at the
situation and see that some of his
people are not succeeding
and when you have calls for one of them
to be impeached and when you have
mayorkis going to the border today and
there's going to be pressure put on him
not even by all republicans
representative cuellar henry cuellar at
the border to talk with mayorkas today
he'll speak before mayorkas does
democrat big voice in the house
the the issue is can you turn off the
spicket
long enough to let us catch up
can you put title 42 back in place long
enough for us not to be so exposed to
more covid coming across the border
what do you say
well first the first images and outrage
were by representative choir i'm glad
that you brought him up and he is the
democrat so to say democrats don't care
is not true when it's destiny no one is
saying secondly i've i've always said
that vice president kamala harris should
have been ages ago at the border but we
also have to look at distinguishing i
was watching a very interesting video by
texas county judge cortez in which he
says you know some we have in the rio
grande especially in texas a
misunderstanding and a misconception of
the labeling of individuals for example
if you are seeking asylum and you come
here with children under the age of six
and you are given a court date you are
then technically here legally until that
court date and until the united states
court should they be testing those
people at the border before we let them
in we also have to look at what's
happened in northern mexico in uh
tamalipas tamalipa says no more children
under six years of age we don't have the
facilities to care for them that has
increased the numbers that we have at
the border these are not excuses these
are realities to joey's point i love you
but this is not an obama trump or biden
problem this is an american problem
that's been going on for 17 years i ask
you an important question semantics
won't fix it
i don't know
we be testing these people for covid
before we let them in asylum is very
specific and when haiti's government
went to hell in a hand basket a couple
of weeks ago after the president was
shot assassinated you saw more haitians
coming to the border those people are
not coming here for necessarily jobs
they're trying to get away from what
potentially could be
a warlike situation so that's asylum and
we will deal with those but title 42 how
do we protect our own citizens you
didn't get to that covet is the number
one thing nobody said all democrats
don't care
henry cuellar is an exception
shannon
the secretary who was going to be down
there today said earlier this year the
border is closed the vice president said
in june we've made extreme progress over
the last few months you talk to anyone
democrat or republican who is there on
the border and they will say that it's
absolutely not true some of that hidden
video that exclusive video that we've
gotten in came through julio rosas who's
been down there many many times works
with townhall.com talked to him last
night he said border agents border
patrol agents are working around the
clock they are terrified for their own
health they are emotionally distraught
by the people and the situations that
they're seeing the trafficking and
everything else that's happening and
they're feeding him this video now
because they are desperate they feel
their administration is not listening to
them hopefully secretary americas will
get a good look at what's actually
happening there today
deal with the reality uh the american
people get it they get this
the polling shows us that and so these
are human beings if we care about human
beings we cannot allow this to continue